hello I'm Steve Lee I'm the Chief Fire
officer of the gold volunteer fire
brigade and I'm fortunate enough to be
the leader of an outstanding crew of 40
men and women who have volunteer
firefighters within the gore of District
communities some of the highlights I've
been the chief here is watching the new
firefighters gain skills and make a
contribution within the community to
help people particularly during their
time of need I'll say to somebody who
wants to join the volunteer fire service
come along be part of a great team learn
some new skills and make a contribution
within the community I'm sure you'll
find it extremely rewarding happy
volunteer week New Zealand and all the
best and thank you for the contributions
made by all volunteers within their
Community it's appreciated